a march of defiance through the streets
of Charleston the shock of this week
shooting has left residents determined
to keep going but asking exactly how it
came to be that nine people were gunned
down inside a church a family friend of
Survivor Felicia Sanders who watched her
26 year old son tywanza die said the
young man tried to negotiate with the
gunman he asked the other person told
the other person that was not necessary
to be doing what he was doing that's
after some of the people had already
been severely wounded tried to talk him
down try to talk peace he was ignored
the mother his last view of her son ty
was crawling over to his auntie and an
effort
and that's her final memory meanwhile a
racist manifesto has emerged online
alongside pictures of the white suspect
charged in connection with the
Charleston murders some images appear to
show 21 year old Dylan roof posing with
the Confederate flag and wax figures
depicting slaves the FBI is
investigating the authenticity of the
images South Carolina is the only u.s.
state that still allows the Confederate
flag to fly outside its Capitol building
many residents view it as a source of
historic pride others say it's a symbol
of slavery and white supremacy past
efforts to take down the flag have
failed but a new movement for its
removal is growing in the wake of this
week's racially motivated killings we
know the heat we know the danger it says
stop it says you are not welcome here it
says fear for your life take down the
flag
we are all members today the historic
emanuel african methodist church where
the massacre took place will reopen its
doors on sunday many hope the worship
will mark the beginning of recovery and
healing for charleston